thank you
oh I like all of you but I think you
cake and Laura and Angie and you big boy
so good evening I want to thank the
Academy's Board of Governors for this
wonderful evening I feel truly honored
to be here and you know what's wonderful
about being an actress is you don't just
live one life yours you live many lives
and for that we we have to thank the
writers after all they're the ones who
start out with a piece of blank paper
and then they create the story and then
they create the characters in the story
and that gives us actors the opportunity
to hopefully bring all those characters
to life and it's another wonderful thing
about being an actress you get to work
with a lot of people often other actors
that you have have long admired I was
especially lucky because I got to work
with many Davis my all-time favorite
we did a picture called strangers and I
was thrilled to death when when I heard
that she was gassed and one day we were
finished with the day's work and we went
balint it to see the dailies that the
film that was out the day before we went
to the screening room
and they turned off the lights and they
started the film and i sat there like
all actors do it at the dailies watching
myself I say if I if I did that too
slowly or if I I didn't know or it quite
right or if it was if it was okay and it
did it did seem okay that day so I was
very happy and the lights went on and I
started to gather myself to leave and I
I looked over and way in the far aisle
it was Betty and the cameraman and they
were too far away for me to hear what
they were saying but their body language
was eloquent betty was
and the cameraman was and since I I was
still you know I was so far away I
couldn't understand what they were
saying but I decided this might be a
good time for me to leave and as I
started for the door Betty call about
Jenna she said would you wait just a
moment please I need to talk to you and
I said sure and she walked over to me
her eyes were were still just blazing
and she said did you see my lips
I thought she was kidding so I said no
did you lose them
and she said that isn't funny I mean my
lips on the film that we just saw they
were bright orange and unnatural orange
and that's his fault because he's the
cameraman and he has to say so about
what colors are on the screen so I think
we ought to get rid of him don't you and
I said well Betty to tell you the truth
I I wasn't paying strict attention I
wasn't noticing the details you love the
colors at all and I I just let my mind
wander I guess and she said oh really
you weren't concentrating you let your
mind wander let me tell you something
you better start concentrating and
paying attention to detail because I'm
telling you you're no spring chicken
yourself
she was so funny we had a great time
well I don't want to talk your heads off
but I would feel remiss if I didn't
mention my late husband John Cassavetes
he wrote me the most magnificent parts
and for other actresses do and and and
sometimes he directed them and I surely
do have to thank him for that
oh and I did want to thank thank the
Board of Governors for introducing me to
this fun fellow tall and shiny and gold
very handsome you know he's just so
elegant that I'll this it that is if
nobody objects I think I'll take him
home with me tonight and I'll
one kiss mom
and I'll find I'll find a wonderful
place for him to sit maybe on the piano
and then everyone who comes to my house
will have a chance to see him and admire
him and love him the way I do
so thanks governors and I'm very happy
to see all of you here tonight in the
audience I am happy to have been able to
spend some time with you thank